taiwanese fighter jets circle the skies
before landing to quickly refuel and
take off again the democratically
self-ruled island is conducting military
exercises to prepare for a potential
assault by chinese forces
beijing considers taiwan its own
territory and says reunification is
inevitable but taiwanese leader cyan wen
disagrees
she says the island is an independent
state and has rejected china's one
country two systems proposal i think it
is the intention of the taiwanese
authority to send a signal to the
chinese authority that they would not
surrender or would not be pressured to
go back to the negotiation table for the
reunification psy has made modernizing
taiwan's military a priority
much of the force relies on equipment
provided by the united states its main
security ally
the biden administration sent an
unofficial delegation to the island in
april and is mulling over allowing its
de facto embassy in washington to change
its name to the more official sounding
taiwan representative office
the moves have inflamed tensions between
washington and beijing
the u.s should abide by the one china
principle and refrain from sending wrong
signals to taiwan independence
in august china's people's liberation
army conducted its orange drills near
the island its fighter jets breached
taiwan's air force defense zone on an
almost daily basis
chinese analysts say taipei's combat
capabilities cannot stand up to beijing
ever since the beginning of the 1960s
china mainland already had sufficient
military power to take over taiwan by
force
china has decided not to do that and
even today china is still talking about
peaceful reunification president xi
jinping however has not ruled out taking
the island by force beijing has removed
term limits on his rule and many here
believe he wants to make reunification
with taiwan a part of his personal
legacy
taiwan has been governed separately
since the chinese civil war in the 1940s
washington's stance of strategic
ambiguity means there is no guarantee it
will aid taipei should beijing attack
as tensions build over the taiwan strait
the island's population of 23 million
are holding their breath and hoping the
status quo will be maintained
katrina yu al jazeera beijing